stephen is in nashville hi stephen
welcome to the ramsay show how can we
help
hey dave hey uh christy huge fans of
what you are doing thanks for taking my
call
thank you sir yeah so
right now i'm in a pretty tough
situation i used to be in a band we
spent about four years building it and
eventually got offered a
record deal at the beginning of 2020 and
unfortunately
the lead singer in my band decided last
minute
that he didn't want me in the band and
cut me out of the record deal
and it's been a back and forth or deal
with our lawyers and their lawyers and
just trying to get what i deserve out of
it especially since i
tracked on all the previous songs that
were sold onto the label
um at this point it doesn't look like
they are going to want to meet in the
middle
and i don't have enough money to take
them to court so my question is
should i keep fighting for what's mine
or should i just let go of and trust god
with it
so is there was there a partnership
agreement how was the ban formed
yeah so it was kind of a it was just
it was started off as a thing formed in
high school so there wasn't really a you
know written agreement or anything like
that it just
started off as a hobby so but i mean
what was your understanding was you were
a partner
yes sir that you were not an employee
right yes sir and was that everyone
else's understanding
yes sir what happened
like why did they kick you out do you
know what's the story
yeah so basically we had been in it for
about four years
and when we were forming up getting to
the record deal
um basically all four of us there's four
band members and we had a new guy come
in
later on in the picture he wasn't an
original band member
and when he had joined uh
basically i guess he just started
manipulating i'm confused how
if your equal partners how one of the
equal partners can decide to kick
somebody out
yes exactly well why don't you just say
i'm not kicked out you are
yeah well apparently the thing is he
already went behind my back without
telling me
he went and had another contract going
and then broke the news to me
what happened so i had there was no so
they did a contract
and everybody else signed it with the
record company and you you weren't
you were cut out of the deal is where it
amounts to
right okay and that's how you kicked you
out okay that's logical i'll see how
that happens
all right okay so what's on you is uh
and we've all done this but you were
young and stupid and you did not do
an agreement in writing and you don't do
anything in business without an
agreement in writing
and it's not because contracts are
magical make people behave
it's because that way there's a real
clear understanding of what the flip is
really going on here
instead we went from garage band and the
back of the van
into a deal with no agreement
and that's where you got screwed and and
so i've done stuff where i left myself
vulnerable
that's what you did and and i ended up
getting screwed because i left myself
vulnerable and what i get from that i
call that stupid tax when i do it
because i pay i lose money because i was
stupid
and uh my trick is in life to never pay
the same stupid tax twice you won't ever
do this one again will you
no sir you'll always have it in writing
from now on
and so um how much money is involved
uh it was a six-figure project so it's
250 000
project is that how much money you would
have gotten one-fourth or one-fifth of
that
um so there would be they didn't specify
exactly how much money up front that the
band members would get but about
90 percent of that 80 i'm guessing 80 to
90 percent of that was definitely used
for just marketing
studio fees okay so you didn't get it
you're getting real money
then so there's there's you know you're
gonna go to court over five thousand
bucks
gotcha i don't think it's worth the
headache stephen i mean the money the
money's a piece of it
it's more just like you just feel
wronged and i get that but you're
continuing to let it steal your peace of
mind
by continuing to worry about it and so
it's just like dave said it's the stupid
tax i think you just cut your losses
walk away move on don't make that
mistake again
and i know you you're on those tracks
and seeing them continue to make music
without you is like that's got to just
like
really get to you but i think if you can
let that go cut those ties and move on
you will feel such a different level of
peace because i just can't even imagine
how draining
this must be on you to worry about
stress about yeah
i mean they owe you for rent in your
head because they've been living in your
head for a while
yeah yeah absolutely that's what
christie's saying
and when you just when you give them the
eviction notice from your head
then you're going to get back to living
life again and move on
i i you know mathematically it's not
worth it to fight you're going to spend
15
20 000 bucks trying to capture five
if you win and uh and i don't
it's not that there's not a principle
here that's worth fighting on
for me especially since you did not get
it in writing and that's on you as well
um and so i think you know i i think the
best thing that would end up happening
is you end up settling or some silly
thing like that
and it's some kind of a moral victory i
just i'm with you i think your first up
suggestion when you came
on the on the line stephen was do i walk
away and let god handle this and the
answer is yes
and that has nothing to do with them it
has nothing to do with what's right or
wrong
uh it has uh and it has nothing to do
you know for there's some things worth
fighting for
um and you you know you allocate money
to fight for it
and it's just because i'm that's a fight
i need to win
just before the lord i'm not gonna get
messed over on this
and i'm gonna fight this one to the
death and so you know we're gonna just
put a budget together for the legal fees
and
we're just gonna be there a while let's
just do it you know game on
uh but most things you're better off to
just go water off a duck's back and move
along
and um i mean this will be a less this
will be something you talk about with
buddies over coffee
20 years from now that happened to you
back when
and it's just that time you learned a
lesson i i would
turn it loose um and you know the other
thing is is that
that you're in nashville and the music
business
really is not that big and so now
this guy every time you're around music
this guy that screws people over he's
got another problem because he's got you
out here screwing up his reputation
because it's screwed up because he lies
and steals
and so it's gonna cost him a lot more
than five thousand dollars over the
scope of his life
because again you're in a fairly small
community of people they're not that
large
and so that you know they word gets out
on a guy and nobody wants to work with
him
and it's you know that that that's going
to cost him
he's the one that's really screwed up
here so anyway that that
and the other thing is you just learned
america about record contracts
we got signed we're going to give you
250 000
except we're really not we're just going
to commit to spend that on you
sorta maybe and we're gonna run up the
studio fees and we're gonna run up the
recording costs and when all this is
done
you're gonna get three dollars and we're
gonna own your masters
and uh then if you get a big hit and
it's so big that it out earns all this
stupidity
then actually you will be a star and
have some money but most of the time
you will just end up with no money and a
record
the other thing stephen i just want to
encourage you is it it feels like that
maybe you you're thinking if you decide
to move on and let this go that it makes
what they did okay and it doesn't
yeah it doesn't make it okay you're just
gonna move on
for your own peace of mind for your own
quality of life for your own progress
and not letting it continue to eat at
you so don't feel like it
somehow dismisses that this was a big
deal it was a big deal
and that hurt and those were your
friends from high school and that was
your music and your art you made
together that
that must really hurt and it's okay to
be hurt and still decide to let it go
and move on
i agree yeah i mean there are things
that hurt you and piss you off and you
remember them
and uh you remember the people and it
you know some of these things
you know it's not a matter of sitting
around holding a grudge and you know
wringing your hands over it but but it
is to
you know if dr john deloney would hear
was there he would say you know
it's a loss and it's a valid loss and
grieving
about a vow and loss of friendship
grieving about a valid loss of being
you know taken to the cleaners by
somebody is um that's a valid thing
you know you got hurt dude and to
christie's point i agree with that
so but if i'm in your shoes you asked uh
i'd move on i've picked my battles
there's some of my fight to the death
but
most of them i don't so there you go